after effects is an easy peasy and i'm
gonna prove it
now
[Music]
hey apostle jerusalem here instructor of
the animation
for designers course today we're gonna
take
a quick tour inside after effects
and you realize that animation is not
that creepy master
inside the closet
we are going to start with some basics
this is how it looks when you start
after effects
on the left side is the project panel
where we can drag and drop
any type of media file i will import
two files one video footage and one
illustrator because i love to keep
things
organized i always suggest creating
folder
based on the media file formats so
i will click the folder icon twice to
create
two different folders i will name them
and drag the media into them now
let's create a composition the
composition is like the artboard on
illustrator
it's our canvas i'm gonna create one
by clicking this icon here it requests
to adjust some
settings but first of all we have to
name it
then to set up the resolution if you are
working on something
for youtube call for the full hd for
instagram post
choose the square resolution and for
instagram stories
go with a portrait all these formats
work for almost any social media
platform
the duration doesn't matter because we
can adjust it at any time
i will go with 20 seconds for now
click ok and it's going to appear inside
the project panel
like everything on after effects the
composition
will look like this or this this is
happening
because it is empty so let's add
something
inside i will drag and drop the feeder
footage inside the timeline
and it's going to appear as a layer the
timeline works similar to the layer
panels of
photoshop and illustrator so
let's add one more asset and this time i
will drop it into the composition screen
yes you can also add things in that way
it will appear another layer on the
timeline
this time is the logo that we added if i
drag the logo
under the footage it will disappear like
a regular
layer panel let's bring it back for now
if you want to preview the timeline just
press the space bar on the keyboard
maybe this will not play back in real
time
so we will set a no top preview
resolution to work faster
this is just for the preview and not the
final export
now it's time to create an animation if
you click
on the arrow next to the layer and then
next to the transform
it will reveal some properties also
you can reveal them one by one with
simple shortcuts
with a layer selected press b for
position
s for scale r for rotation and
t for opacity now if you press shift
and one of the shortcuts it will keep
the previous one
let's try it for this one we need
rotation
so i will press r and position
so i will hold shift and press b now we
have them both
to change the position of a layer you
can do it by clicking
on the selection tool here and drag it
wherever you want
or by adjusting the values of the
position
also you can change the size by dragging
these points i'm gonna move the logo
somewhere here
on the right bottom of the screen for
this one we need to create a slide
animation
from right to left something like this
i'm gonna use the edges of the screen to
hide the logo
and then reveal it we need to tell after
effects that
how with keyframes
so i'm gonna move forward two seconds on
the timeline
and i'm gonna click on this stopwatch a
keyframe has been created
and this icon proves that now we need to
set another keyframe
for the first position outside of the
screen
i will go back at zero seconds
and move the logo by holding the shift
until it disappears the shift key holds
the position
in the line of the movement without
going up and down
after effects creates another keyframe
at the new position
and if you press space bar you can
preview your first animation
and it's the best animation ever made
but because there is
always room for improvement let's make
it better
in the real world things accelerate and
decelerate
and we can make this easily inside after
effects
i will highlight the keyframes
right click on them go keyframe
assistant
and then easy's but the day
has only 24 hours and we can spend it on
more productive things for that we can
go
with a favorite shortcut of every
animator out there
the f9 if you press f9 the keyframes
icon will change
let's press space for preview and the
animation is much smoother
we can make this animation way more
interesting
by adjusting thesings
[Music]
if we highlight the keyframes again and
click on the graph editor
it will reveal the speed curve of the
layer it's easy to understand it
at this point the object is not moving
because the curve is at zero going
forward
it starts to accelerate
[Music]
until this time and then decelerates
until it stops so let's try something
i need the acceleration to start sooner
and then
smoothly slow down i'll grab
the second point and drag it on the left
now the curves change with the top
points more on the left side
this means that the speed dab will start
sooner
spacebar for preview and the animation
is really more
interesting we can adjust the duration
of the movement
by changing the space between the two
keyframes
if you move it closer it will be faster
if you move it further away it's gonna
be slower
now i need to do the same animation for
the rotation
now let's create and animate a text
in the top toolbar we can find a text
icon
also set layers to create simple things
a pen tool to draw lines
a zoom tool but i prefer to use the
control
or command plus and minus shortcut
and the hand tool to move around the
composition
let's pick the text tool and type
something
on the right we have a group of panels
like the effect and presets
the character the align and more we can
hide and
hide them from the window menu now
if we go to the character panel with the
layer selected
we can adjust size
tracking colors
[Music]
and more but i need to make the text
more readable for that we can add
something behind it
we're gonna pick the shape layer tool
and create a simple box
and place it under the text in layers
order
now we can also adjust the position by
using the arrows
on the keyboard we can create a custom
animation
but i'm going to use the presets of
after effects for this one
let's start with the text i'm going to
select the text
and go on the effects panel animation
presets
presets text
animation in because we need to create a
reveal
and i'm gonna choose the typewriter by
drag it into the layer
or we can go with a simple double click
now something cool
if you press u with a layer selected it
will reveal
only the properties with the keyframes i
need this to be faster
so as we said i'm gonna move it closer
to the first one
now we can create the same animation for
the shape
i will go again on the effects panel
and this time i'm gonna search for the
wipe transition
like before i will drag it into the
shape layer
now i'm going to create this animation
smoother with the f9
and make an adjustment to the speed it
will be better
for this lower third to show up after
the logo to do that
i will select both layers and move them
forward on the timeline
now the text and the shape enter the
screen in a second time
because the end point of the layers
starts
after the video footage and the logo
to export this amazing animation with
the composition selected
go composition and click on add to adobe
media encoder queue
it's gonna run another software where we
can adjust
the export settings the most common
format for the internet is the mp4
for that choose the h264
then hit ok and then the green play
button
and your video will be ready in a couple
of seconds
that's all guys thanks for watching
don't forget to check
our course i explain step by step how to
become
a professional animator and i share some
really cool tips
this was apostle los and until next time
stay creative
and welcome to the future